[Music]
and sex and news so I'm going to buy
super glue for the lube oh you'll be
second side forever angry parents want
to ban a sex ed program that literally
tells students what sex is where is it
that this is actually up in cupertino
district you know aren't they super
liberal where it is cooper's in a big
area what doesn't sex that I already
tell you what tested yes hmm
so they think they focus more on the
birthing and the Adaline enlighten we
will tell you how for your dick in the
woman I don't remember that I don't
remember any of that
well the school's not have a teacher are
these parents going to teach it because
a lot of times our [ __ ] shy
I want school to teach my kids about
that [ __ ] dude I love that I really do
yeah so do it the right way because
they'll do it very scientifically can i
giggle to the whole thing that's true I
don't want to have to tell my kids that
I got horny and I stuck it in and we
were like I flipped your mom over to
this and down thank you to say father
when I was about to but I could feel my
big haul say and go I want to say all
that stuff like a little orca whale baby
Thomas has a child and do more hard I
don't want a hot dick
I don't want explain it my way yeah the
teacher anything anyone wants my mom
looks like a cross out of the public eye
I don't want to go in gang signs as a
gender No so from grades 7 to 12 of in
California there was this act that was
passed back in 2015 with Jerry Brown and
the act is called California healthy
youth act and pretty much what this act
wants to do is to provide pupils with
the knowledge and skills necessary to
protect their sexual reproductive health
from HIV and other sexually transmitted
in and from unintended pregnancy and
provide pupils with the knowledge and
skills they need to develop healthy
attitudes concerning adolescent growth
and development body image gender sexual
orientation relationships marriage and
family and so Wow what's wrong with that
good exact so that is great too
10th grade to 12 12 and what that's
around the time that they should be
learning about this [ __ ] yeah and so for
the sex the seventh grade curriculum
there's actually like different
curriculums out there but for chapter
one doggystyle well for the Cooper for
the Cupertino Union School District they
selected as one curriculum and this
curriculum was apparently too graphic
yeah too graphic for the parents liking
to watch pornos in class well no because
wait dick sucking does it look like Kama
Sutra [ __ ] pictures well no the
parents were just saying that I like
Kama Sutra pictures because a guy always
has a hat on the whole time I don't know
how they like acceptable hazard his
ankle behind his back while he's [ __ ]
a girl I don't know why has a hat on and
the girls got bracelets under ankles
which is naked you know no like so a lot
of the parents they're saying that this
is really inappropriate
really age inappropriate for our seventh
graders because it's too graphic and
like you're actually literally like
defining what the sex is so like include
like anal or also national sex they been
seeing this [ __ ] huh baby they saw this
[ __ ] in sixth grade what the [ __ ] I
would prefer it maybe 14 freshman year
of high school yeah you know because
there's like service 70s 12 11 12 or
maybe they should make it like maybe
like a three year process where in the
beginning it starts off kind of vague
and you understand it but at the end it
should be crystal clear as to like what
the STDs are how to do it the types of
ways like anal vaginal whatever so
there's nothing that's a mystery you
know they can fuel if you feel comforted
things are forms of pleasure and has
nothing to do with reproduction so I
mean like oral sex will be educated on
it especially if you're trying to
prevent getting STDs and things like
that
plus I get it's kind of that-that-that's
ulema
where it's like well would you rather
have your kid getting drunk out in a
crack party rather than at Holabird I
think my point is that those things are
very an ancillary so the point of it is
to teach kids about SD and you could do
that just with the reproductive organ
alone which is very scientific and
that's the part that they want you to
learn but I think it's up to a parent to
decide like well those extra stuff I
could do that I just need you to focus
on this part you know that's a good
point yeah you don't want chapter 11 the
[ __ ] different anal beads
yeah like deep throating you don't
really like 12 oh you know doll [ __ ]
I learned that but then do you think
that learning about anal vaginal and
oral sex and seventh grade is too early
for me it would be a little early I
would prefer that that kind of stuff I
think that ancillary stuff like ass
[ __ ] mouth [ __ ] and [ __ ] I want to
teach the kid about that but we're gonna
call you a mouse a mouse but I'll see
I'll tell them what it is you know what
I mean to fight you don't have a condom
come in the bow there you go but then
what about the kids who won't even talk
to them about that
I feel like they're taking away all of
the fun in childhood like exploring that
[ __ ] learning from your friends being
taught by or [ __ ] like filling up
each other with your girlfriend [ __ ]
that's where you learn also so you got
to think about this too like if you're
teaching kids about anal sex and
exploring sexuality in that way that's
also gets religious beliefs to autonomy
you know stuff like that people might
not me and wit it exactly so you're also
stepping over your bones you program one
where they get extreme and then the
parents have to like to sign for that
like a piece itself or at least when I
went they had to sign for section you do
any sex that you got to here I'm
desperate sex runners honors sex but in
SMM and bondage for 12th grade yeah in
that time if it's for 7th to 12th you
know if there is like septic report with
thing because then for that huge age
range like there should be like more age
appropriate yeah I actually think they
should do community age-appropriate ooh
so it fairly have statistics that in
certain area
people are more likely to get pregnant
earlier mmm they should probably start
just in sex ed yet like a little bit
earlier in other communities where
people aren't as sexually active maybe
they can prolong it and then be a little
more in detail later on you should be
like driver's ed where they [ __ ] for
example Ernest and then you get your
[ __ ] license Oh hands-on experience
what were some of the complaints that
discerns were saying telework autopilot
and then they have the curriculum
beforehand like the parents obtain the
curriculum and they were able to see you
so supposedly before the school
announces the new curriculum the school
is supposed to have the curriculum up
online for parents to see the general
area but when they were having the
meeting about like okay what do you all
one of all of you guys think about this
curriculum a lot of times are like what
it's like we never remember saw this
online like it was never available so
the first time I'm hearing about this
and like they're they're like looking
into into like what they will be
teaching and so what was they were
saying was that it was in age of age
inappropriate my boys would you could do
this to me and at the curriculum this is
going to contain two scenarios that that
were designed to increase curiosity like
in terms of sexuality and so it's like
they didn't want eyes like why don't
[ __ ] would you want to increase
curiosity like you're overstepping
Safran I'm curious about being
homosexual we'll just try with the buddy
yeah soccer dick yes curricula was
specifically for seventh graders and
attention unlike it for the seventh
graders is a little yeah I agree
chapter nine explore ever thought about
jacking off your buddies yeah I
preferred like the whole scientific fact
thing if we want to talk about pleasure
and what the cons let you come to sex
with the anatomy yeah no no I was like
well what about but something as well I
wouldn't know because mommy does let me
do it so for example in the curriculum
like oral sex right so they defined oral
sex as putting your mouth on someone's
penis or on someone's penis your penis
or vulva
so and then are you is putting your
peanuts inside of someone or having some
like inside of your vagina so it's like
it's a very like clear statement and a
lot of the Pens are just like oh no like
they're just trying to teach like our
kids do like sex examples versus giving
us facts about it that is that it is
that so that's that's the that's a
controversy for like well we are giving
you guys facts we're like I don't know
where there is communication what kind
of dumb [ __ ] do they think the students
are at sixth grade you could you could
get curious and type on button Google
what the definition is for [ __ ] oral
sex I just don't want my kids to be
something in a pregnant that's all as
long as you do your job and you tell my
kids like a [ __ ] don't get pregnant
drink alright thank you
some day my [ __ ] kid that little [ __ ]
in them or my [ __ ] sons like [ __ ]
over this [ __ ] I feel like that fifth
grade if you if you if we had like
internet fifth grade we will just type
that [ __ ] in what what's fellatio oh
yeah
what's this this should make sex ed the
movie so it starts off for like some
innocent boy and it goes to school and
you learn all these things throughout
the movie and by the time you're done
with the movie you learn it in a really
fun way and now you learn everything too
I don't want to see that movie but done
in a animation I blanked out what's that
what's that one cartoon from the 70s if
they were to choose full house rock that
one hmm
they're like in a schoolhouse Roxanna
listen good you should do it in anime
style
yeah okay just pull a little bit yeah
but about sex yeah are they cool they
need to desensitize that [ __ ] or I'm
gonna bust out have a bunch of kids on
his gram jacking off all day dude
Justin I'm just imagining just like I
have a daughter she comes in she was
dead I'm pregnant
[ __ ] man [ __ ] go congratulations
awesome oh my god I did not your little
princess paperclip not just a princess
thing it's like probably like who who
impregnated you Jaden Smith Oh
good job honey yeah it's been weird it's
like yo man your dad taught you about
condoms and [ __ ] but you don't know
where the [ __ ] is dirty ass [ __ ]
babies your [ __ ] head dumb ass is
wrong with you god damn it
and so you like feeling like I got a new
puppy you're pregnant
look oh look at that the caveman had to
work for it so if it's a boy and he got
a girl he's like a stop in the face yeah
I mean [ __ ] I'll keep the baby and kick
that girl out of the house this
curriculum did not pass because there
was a two to two vote aye and so now the
school district needs to come up with a
new curriculum that's only two parents
another two parents will fight mat it
there's only four terms that showed up I
gave a plus two said yes who said well
no no I mean contractures parents
parents of petition there's a lot of
petitions for this it was like about
perfect entire curriculums which is kind
of like pickin and just like kind of
create what they want well supposedly um
the school district thing had about a
year to like come up with this
curriculum but what a lot of parents are
speculating is like oh like you know the
school district is really trying to like
get this out of the way first because
they're going to get like a lawsuit
because they needed to like enforce a
new curriculum that meets the new state
standards at a certain time and so like
because they didn't want to get like so
a long time spent because they don't
wanna get like feed they just like take
the already a made curriculum and just
say like yeah we approve of this so
there was just a school being lazy not
time to tailor it for the student yeah
so like they just want to like oh we got
to get this out right away so that we
don't get respectively yes this is what
they're speculating and then like
they're also saying like well you know
what like they're eventually going to
get charged because they didn't do their
job like they didn't take out what would
be net like appropriate for our kids to
learn so like now like because
curriculum is being sent back and they
have to like take on a different one
these parents are delusional they're
acting like this is going to be the
first exposure the kids have to sex
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] the kids
need school if you want to [ __ ] teach
children need to start earlier Kenny
bottom [ __ ] I did yeah I thought
it
and that's why sex ed is good like
talking minion Ivana's body like little
baby little baby baby ohh i thought oh
okay
aren't you taking Peter bubble Java sure
no no I'm still having that in there oh
god I was like well I bet Google Gaga
behind it that should be taught by
friends especially that should something
you talk about that's like the joys of
childhood we talk about it with your
friends what about that's when I'm girl
kisses your wiener oh and I think I
would want to tell him like what it is
but technically I'm your friend
it's his friends like you know what a
[ __ ] is of course my mother told me
that's over here
that's so weird when I just how about
told me already I don't even know him he
means to know hey guys how did you guys
like that J can use episode well let us
know by liking the video for more videos
click right over here
[Music]